jusqu'où peut aller une pile de cartes
est ce qu'il ya une distance limite
théorique jusqu'à laquelle la pile de
cartes peut aller de déborder de la
table où est ce que la pile de cartes
peut aller aussi loin que l'on veut tout
en restant en équilibre sur la table
alors il s'agit d'un emprunt de maths
que je trouve vraiment cool donc je vous
invite vraiment un maître poser vraiment
essayer de trouver une piste de
réflexion pour essayer de résoudre ce
problème d'un point de vue théorique
d'un point de vue mathématique et
pendant ce temps je vais essayer de
faire tendre cette pile de cartes aussi
loin que possible une carte est donné
ghailani d'une personne pas de quartier
à deux cartes commencé avec une bonne
base assez solide
pas tout à fait de cartes
le quartier
ce que j'ai réussi mes trois kurt
donc pour info j'ai là 200 cartes de
cartes de visite sur ensemble dans sa
carte de vie et je vous invite essaie de
faire chez vous envoyez moi des images
de vous en train d'essayer de faire ça
et c'est pas super plaisir que je vous
presser dans les commentaires les
prochains épisodes
alors vous allez trouver à quel point
est-ce qu'une pile de cartes des bordées
d'une table un mètre 5 mètres 10 m à
l'infini un bon réflexe de matheux
consiste à commencer par le cas le plus
simple
je vous propose donc de considérer le
cas avec une seule carte de combien peut
être débordé d'une table tout en gardant
son équilibre facile d'une demi cartes
et ça c'est parce que pour que la carte
soit en équilibre
son centre de gravité doit rester sur la
table ce qui implique que pas plus de la
moitié de la carte se trouve au delà de
la table pour simplifier on va supposer
qu'une carte entière fait deux décimales
de gens du coût de 1000 cartes ça fait 1
dessinée et du coup si j'ai une seule
carte
je peux la faire déborder de la table
d'un des six mètres
ce père que jusque là tout va bien on va
compliquer un petit peu que se
passe-t-il maintenant si l'on a deux
cartes de combien la peep été dépassée
la table et réfléchir pour que les deux
cartes reste en équilibre
il faut deux conditions en premier lieu
il faut que les deux cartes ensemble
soit en équilibre sur la table ce qui
revient à dire que le centre de gravité
des deux cartes doit se trouver
au-dessus de la table
en second lieu il faut que la carte du
dessus soit en équilibre sur la carte du
dessous et ça ça revient à dire que le
centre de gravité de la carte du dessus
doit se trouver au dessus de la carte du
dessous voici ce que je vous propose
je vais faire dépasser la carte du
dessous de la moitié d'une 2000 cartes
ça nous fait avancer d'un demi des six
mètres
puis vint carte du dessus va dépasser la
carte du dessous d'une demi carte le
total aura donc dépasser la table d'un
des six mètres et demi
ok mais est ce que cette configuration
internet qui vivent le centre de gravité
de la carte du dessus est la moitié
d'une demie car tout delà de la terre
mais le centre de gravité de la carte du
dessous lui est une moitié de dému carte
à l'intérieur de la table du coup le
centre de gravité des deux cartes qui
est à mi chemin entre les deux centres
de gravité se trouve au bord de la table
la première condition d'équilibré donc
vérifié par ailleurs on voit que le
centre de gravité de la carte du dessus
et bien au bord de la carte du dessous
ce qui garantit la seconde condition d'
équilibre d'ailleurs on peut vérifier
que ces deux conditions sont vérifiées
juste à leurs limites
ce qui suggère que la configuration
qu'on a choisi est en fête
donc si je récapitule avec une carte n'a
dépassé la table d'un des six mètres
avec deux cartes on l'a dépassée d'un
des six mètres et demi
ce que vous voyez le pater c'est pas
très clair encore en passant à trois
cartes
je vais maintenant faire dépasser la
carte du dessous d'un tiers de deluz
cartes et placer les deux cartes du
dessus sur la carte du dessous comme
j'avais placé les deux cartes sur la
table tout à l'heure on sait que le
centre de gravité des deux cartes du
dessus dépasse maintenant la table d'un
tiers de 2000 cartes et il est associé
un poids de 2 car il correspond à deux
cartes
al'inverse le centre de gravité de la
carte du dessus est d'une de 1000 cartes
dont un tiers de 2000 cartes à
l'intérieur de la table ce qui
correspond à être deux tiers de 2004 à
l'intérieur
la table le centre de gravité global
correspond donc à deux tiers de 2000
cartes vers l'intérieur
plus deux fois un tiers de comic art
vers l'extérieur ce qui place ce centre
de gravité global juste au bord de la
table et trois cartes ensemble ont donc
être en équilibre sur la table enfin on
voit que l' équilibre des deux cartes du
dessus sur la carte du dessous est
équivalent au cas où on n'avait que deux
cartes sur la table dont on a déjà
prouvé l' équilibre
cette fois on a avancé d'un des six
mètres + 1/2 décimètre plus un tiers des
6 mètres ce qu'on commençait à avoir
loupé pour énne carte
je vais faire dépasser la carte du
dessous d'un énième de 2000 cartes puis
je vais mettre les aides - une autre
carte sur la carte du dessous comme je
les oreilles mise sur la table
le centre de gravité des ailes - une
carte hui dessus et 1 sur rennes au delà
de la table alors que la carte du
dessous un centre de gravité d'une demi
carte - 1 sur rennes de 2000 cartes vers
l'intérieur de la table un petit calcul
de barycentre montrent maintenant que le
centre de gravité de toutes les cartes
va se retrouver exactement au bord de la
table
du coup les haines cartes sont bien en
équilibre sur la table tandis que par
récurrence les haines moins une carte du
dessus sont en équilibre sur la carte du
dessous paumé leur étaient sur la table
dont convient des pastels à table en
décimètres n cars vont dépasser la table
d'un des six mètres plus un demi
décimètre plus un tiers et un quart est
ainsi de suite jusqu'à 1 sur rennes
c'est ce que l'on appelle la somme
harmonique ca sound est inverse des
haines premiers nombres entiers
strictement positif du coup la question
c'est est ce qu'on peut aller très loin
avec la somme harmonique est ce que
cette semaine harmonique peut devenir
aussi grande que l'on veut est ce
qu'elle peut devenir plus grand que
l'ong de g
ou est ce que on atteint
limite comme dans le paradoxe de zénon
qu'on ne pourra jamais dépasser
qu'en pensez vous pour répondre à ces
questions d sinon départ de camembert
qui représente toutes les fractions en 1
sur rennes veut mettre de côté les deux
plus grosses parts colons maintenant les
par un tiers et un quart puis les par un
cinquième à un huitième puis celle entre
un neuvième et un 16e et ainsi de suite
vous remarqué quelque chose tous les
ensembles de parc j'ai construit ainsi
font au moins un demi camembert c'est
parce que le cayenne ensemble contient
deux puissances qu'à part et que tout
sépare font au moins un sur deux
puissances capucins mais j'ai alors une
infinité d'ensemble de taille au moins
un demi camembert et avoir plus qu'une
infinité de 2 me tiens lambert ça fait
une quantité infinie de camembert et
donc même si moi je ne suis pas parvenu
on pourrait en principe faire une pile
de cartes qui dépasse la table aussi
loin que l'on veut qui pourra aller à
des googleplex de mètres et rejoindre
mon doppelganger tout là bas ça paraît
complètement fou tellement fou que l'on
peut vraiment se demander est ce que
c'est vraiment possible en pratique on
peut être pas un googleplex de m est ce
qu'il est possible disant de faire une
pile de cartes comme sakineh passe à
table qui du coup en jambes le lac léman
ou tout simplement qui atteint le mur
qui l'a se trouve à dix mètres d'ici et
bien le mur il est a dit m si ça ça fait
sans les six mètres
or on a vu qu'une pile de ncaa retrouvé
débordé de la table de indécis m + 1/2
puissant tir accepter jusqu'à 1 sur
rennes
autrement dit il faut une valeur de
haine tels que la somme harmonique
jusqu'à 1 sur rennes dépasse la valeur
sans est ce que mille cartes suffirait
si je fais la seule arme neige jusqu'à
1000 j'obtiens 7 donc avec 1000 cartes
en fait je ne peux dépasser la table que
2,7 des six mètres ce qui est pas mal
hein c'est presque un mètre mais on
n'est pas du tout prêt des dix mètres
qu'il faut pour arriver jusqu'au mur
est-ce que du coup un million de cartes
devraient suffire ainsi vous faire un
saut marmonné jusqu'à un million
j'obtiens seulement 14
est ce que un milliard de cartes
suffirait toujours pas avec un milliard
de cash peut déborder de la table de
seulement 21
des six mètres un peu plus de deux
mètres et pas plus qu'est ce qui se
passe en fait au xviiie siècle grand
léonarde colère a prouvé que cette somme
harmonique jusqu'à 1 sur rennes
vale est à peu près le logarithme
n'était rien de head qui est à peu près
égale à 2,3 fois le nombre de chiffres
de haine
en fait l'oc ii n sera exactement le
nombre de chiffres de haine si l'on
écrivait l embase e ou un e et le nombre
de l'air et vaut à peu près 2,718 mais
je vous reparlerai sans doute de tout ça
une prochaine fois
tout ça pour dire que le nombre de
quatre qui pourrait faire une pile qui
va aller jusqu'au mur qui a dit m d'ici
et de l'ordre d'un nombre de 100 chiffre
en fait un bond de son chiffre en base
eux c'est à dire aux puissances sent bon
pour ceux qui préfèrent utiliser la base
dit ça correspond à un nombre à 43
chiffre à peu près 10 kg ans 43 12
il faut donc à peu près une discussion
ce 43 carte pour arriver au mur qui a
dit m ici disputant ce 43e c'est un
nombre incroyablement grand déjà parlé
du très grand nombre dans un épisode
précédent
c'est plus grand que le nombre des
toiles dans l'univers que si on a
réfléchi un petit peu ça veut dire que
si je veux aller au mur jusqu'à jusque
là bas il faut 10 puissance 40 cartes et
même en supposant que chaque carte est
extrêmement fine effet à dison 0,1 mm
d'épaisseur
si on empile 10 puissance 43 carte
j'obtiens calmes et une pile qui va
faire 10 puissance 36 kilomètres de haut
ce qui est plus que la taille de notre
univers donc non je pourrais jamais
faire une pile aussi hors du coup
pourrait jamais faire une pile qui va
jusqu'au mur l'anr fois on a parlé de
l'intérêt à égalité 0,9 9,9 est égal à 1
et l j j a fait remarquer dans les
commentaires que jean paul ii l'air
récemment écrit un article dans pour la
science dans le dernier pour la science
même qui paraît justement de cette
égalité et qui proposait des systèmes de
nombre dans lequel il n'y avait pas
égalité 9-9 et est strictement
inférieure à 1 et on va du coup il est
passé en revue
mais avant de parler de ses méthodes un
peu bizarroïdes
je vais insister sur le fait qu'il faut
absolument pas faire ce que je vais dire
à l'école sont des trucs qui correspond
à des maths assez étrange qui sont pas
du tout pratique utile ni les trucs qui
vous êtes censé savoir donc ne prenez
pas ce que je vais dire comme un truc
qui énorme une convention établie
ceci étant dit l'une des grandes joies
des mathématiques et des mathématiciens
c'est essayer de voir un angle opposé à
celui qu'on dit du coup c'est assez
marrant en tout cas aux autres il y à
des systèmes de nombre intéressant
mary-kate on a en fait différent de 1 et
en gros si on veut que 0,9 9,9 soit
différent de 1
il faut que les preuves qu'on a sorti ne
tiennent plus la route en particulier la
preuve dieu un tiers que fontaine
présente dans les commentaires il faut
qu'elle soit fausse quelque part en gros
cette preuve elle contient deux étapes
la première c'est de dire qu' un tiers
est égal à 3 3 3 à l'infini et la
deuxième consiste à dire que 0333 à
l'infini x 3 est égal à 0,9 9,9 et c'est
aussi égale à 3 fois retière qui est
quasiment par définition du 1/3 égal à 1
du coup on à 0,9 de sa filiale à nous il
ya deux étapes dans ce raisonnement et
si l'on veut que 0,9 soit différent il
faut que ce raisonnement soit faux dans
l'une des deux étapes au moins est ce
que propose de faire jean paul ii la
hesse le supposer que la deuxième étape
est fausse c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
fait 0,3 3 3 3 3 x 3 ou ne tient pas à
0,9 9,9 neuf donc le système de
numération que propose jean paul de lay
pour justifier le fait que leurs règles
9 à 9
pour être différent de 1 c'est pas
quelque chose qu'il en donne c'est juste
une façon de présenter un nombre qui
justifierait le fait que ça soit
différent de 1 et jean paul de lay très
bien qu'il s'agisse d'une façon
alternative de penser et mat qui a
beaucoup de défauts cette approche de
jean paul de lay correspondance à
imposer que l'on traîne toujours
l'approximation vers le haut juste après
avoir fait une addition une
multiplication donc si on fait une
multiplication trois fois 033 on est
obligé juste après avoir fait la
multiplication de prendre l'arrondi vers
le haut et du coup de remplacer 0,99
pains et à ce moment là on obtient un
système de numération qui satisfait à
peu près les propriétés classique qui
est claire et parfaitement consistant le
premier avec ça c'est que l'on perd des
bonnes propriétés notamment à ce qu'on
fait un x 9,9
n'oubliez d'arrondir vers le haut juste
après la multiplication dont on obtient
forcément un
et ça ça veut dire que 1 n'est plus
l'élément neutre de la multiplication un
élément neutre c'est un élément qui
laisse invariants ce par quoi il est
multipliée tout en maintenant 6 1 était
un élément neutre il faudrait que 1 fois
n'importe quoi ça fasse le n'importe
quoi et en particulier un x 0,9 devrait
être égal à 0,9 9,9 ce qui n'est pas le
cas dans ce système de numération donc
ça c'est ce que jean paul de lay appelle
les nombres de l'élève récalcitrants
c'est un truc qui a encore une fois pas
du tout standard et qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de défauts une autre approche
pour justine fait que 9 9 9 fois plus
petit strictement plus petit gain et une
approche proposée par rich man qui
correspond à dire qu'en fait les
écritures décimales ne correspond pas à
des nombres réels terre peut pas écrire
en fait sa première attaque ne peut pas
un tiers était égal à 0,3 trop trop trop
il n'y a pas de connexion directe entre
le nombre réel et les écritures
décimales infini
ça peut paraître bizarre de faire ça
mais on peut quand même imposé tout une
structure algébrique l ensemble des
nombres écrit sous forme de décimales
infini
notamment on va pouvoir définir
l'addition et la multiplication par
contre à s'interdire la soustraction et
en effet à ce moment là l'addition ne
sera plus un objectif c'est à dire que
typiquement un +6 va souvent être égal à
1 099 plus x mais on n'a pas droit de
simplifier parisé deux côtés du coup on
peut pas déduire de cette égalité
le fait que 1 est égal à 0,9 en
particulier la soustraction que vous
avez présenté dans l'épisode précédent
on n'a pas le droit de la faire ce qui
parle qui empêchent de conclure qu'un
est égal à zéro dit non donc c'est super
bizarre
et lorsque l'on fait ça on obtient un
ensemble de mon cri sous forme de cimade
qui est un semi anneaux seulement
commutatif où le mot soumis correspond
au fait qu'on n'a pas le droit à la
soustraction repart a dénombré 1 dans
cette série avec plein de trucs très
subtil enfin il ya une troisième façon
d'expliquer le fait que 0,9 9,9 pour
être strictement plus petit turin
il envoie encore entré dans des mondes
très bizarre on va rentrer dans le monde
dénombre dix y perd réel donc les
nombres ip réel ça contient une ombre et
de base mais ça contient aussi des
infinitésimaux et on va aussi reparler
de tout ça mais en gros l'analyse non
standard s'appuie sur ses ip réel et
permet de donner un sens au fameux dx
mise et de la physique qu'on utilise
beaucoup en physique en faisant plein de
quelques qui sont pas rigoureux du tout
mais au final ça marche
l'analyse non standard et nombreux hyper
yale c'est tout un format qui permet de
dire qu'en fait ce qu'ils ont fait les
physiciens errigo son qui nous sommes et
dans sept ports y dénombre hyper réel il
ya notamment des infinitésimaux
c'est-à-dire des banques sur ce
territoire positif mais qu'ils soient
plus petits que tous nos maux réels
en fait si on veut écrire parfaitement
un nombre hyper réel il faut préciser
non seulement cndd et simone mais aussi
ses décibels qui sont après les
décimales classique la façon plus
formelle de dire ça c'est qu'il n'y a
pas seulement un nombre infini de
décimales mémorable mais le nombre de
décimales en fait qu'il faut écrire
précisé un ampli père et elle est plus
grand que omega que le plus petit
ensemble infinie et du coup si on écrit
0,9 9,9 avec des points on pourrait
sous-entendre analyse le standard avec
une ont ripé réel qu'en fait on n'a
qu'un nombre dénombrable de neuf qui va
jusqu'à aux pros du sco premier ordinale
infinie on va reparler aussi des
ordinaux dans cette série mais du coup
ils n'ont que des neuf après aux médias
après le premier ordinale infini ce
qu'il veut ce qui impliquerait qu'on n'a
pas en fait sous l'ombre et pérenne qui
est juste au dessous de 1 et du coup il
y avait encore de l'espace entre 0,9 et
on analyse hyper est elle si on
considère encore une fois accusé réguler
9h09 sous longtemps qu'il n'ya qu'à
nombre dénombrable de 9 derrière la
virgule et j'espère vous avez aimé cette
vidéo pour sa faire des piles de cartes
de chez vous voir des vidéos de vos
piles de cartes qui tendent aussi loin
que possible et j'essaierai d'inclure
ces images
vidéo si vous arrivez à me les envoyer
avant le lieu en semaine je vous
conseille aussi très fortement la vidéo
d'un jj sur l'escargot de garner qui est
un point assez différent de la pile de
cartes mais dont la résolution devait
intervenir aussi cette série unique
du coup vous allez voir des liens entre
ceux qui prennent de l'escargot et le
pommeau depuis le quartier soit disant
qu'à réduire aussi de sortir une vidéo
sur le paradoxe bernard parce que
j'aurais pu vous parler dans cette série
s'annonce fort et en fait je crois je
vais pas en parler sur 500 frs sam
économisera un épisode et je pourrais
vous parler de quelque chose d'autre du
coup ça sera plutôt cool si vous avez
aimé cet épisode pensée de l'ikea le
commentaire et de partage et pensez à
vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les
prochains épisodes merci au type heures
pour l'heure donc et j'espère que je
verrai la prochaine fois l'escargot
devra avancer pendant quinze millions de
milliards de milliards de milliards de
milliards d'eur usage des logarithme va
devenir un véritable honneur pour les
mathématiciens car il permet de
transformer les multiplications en
addition